I'm talking about climate change I care
about climate change I've been vegan I
cycle where possible
I recycle religiously next totally with
me on this world but whenever we talk
about these measures and the ills of
long-haul flights and diesel cars I'm
beginning to feel like there is an
elephant in the room it's not just niche
it's this nothing you do in your life to
improve your carbon footprint can come
even close to the impact of this one
simple measure have one less child
that's right a recent study found that
each extra child you have monumentally
eclipses all your other contributions to
reducing carbon emissions the rich of
the nation you live in the greater the
problem why do we endlessly obsess over
separating our rubbish when the most
effective way to combat climate change
is so glaringly obvious the cultural
sensitivities are clear as a parent I am
the last person to lecture others about
the meaningfulness of having children
but it's because I have a child that I
care about the world she'll grow up in
and the more children we have the more
trouble the world that's going to be
[Music]
well then you would hate my family
because I am one of six and if you would
suggest it to my family not sir
you know to have one less child that
would be my amazing little brother that
I adore one of my biggest joy is if not
the biggest joy that I have in my life
is my family my nieces my brothers my
sister when we get together it brings me
so much joy and if you said to me okay
reduce the number of kids and you can
live an extra 20 years I'm happy with my
family I'm happy with you know having
shorter time on earth and it being
quality joyful time I think you should
get rid of one of your siblings me I
would be up for that sometimes but now
on a serious note I think that actually
these things will correct themselves
because I think if you look in the UK as
well women are having children older
than what they used to and I think that
by pure biology
you will be having less but if you give
me the opportunity to have six kids I'd
love to unfortunately we we have
children later in life and it probably
not practical to have those numbers
anymore I'm afraid a fur is absolutely
right but this is one of these metals
that that government's very rarely grasp
when Indira Gandhi tried to grasp and in
India she ended up on if you're in
funeral pyre it doesn't go too well down
well in the hustings but i think it's
incredibly important we have a
population policy just as we have a
climate change policy the two things
that completely just before you guys
leave alone we spoke to some rising we I
do I will bring you in we spoke to women
in Australia who's got quite an extreme
commitment to this just listen to what
she said had to say this is Harriet spot
I know these views can sound really
extreme but I'm just being realistic if
I can't have children naturally and I'm
committed to creating a better world
through my own actions then I can't
justify having children to a sperm donor
IVF I know plenty of women that can have
children naturally and are deciding not
to because of the impact of climate
change so some people are taking this
really literally and I think for me one
of the issues is and I'm interesting
what you guys think is that our foreign
policy and international development
policy is to try and control population
growth in the developing world as a way
of reducing poverty and and also if
we're honest reducing my great pressure
on European countries we preach to other
countries that they should reduce number
of children we have I have never heard a
senior politician in this country even
raise it when I when I saw this
statistic it was the first time I even
knew that having a child has such an
impact on your home currently say there
are lots and lots of issues around it
majid i think it's a bit of a no-brainer
to say that if you're not alive you're
gonna have a zero carbon in that's
basically what we're saying here okay
and well you're saying just don't have a
child and it's gonna have a zero carbon
input the way they work this out this
figure by the ways they basically
projected the carbon imprint of your
child and then it's children and then
divided that between the two parents but
there's some assumptions there for
example that they are going to carry on
reproducing at the rate that we are we
already have the lowest some of the
lowest reproduction rates
in the world in the West and I think
though it's laudable because certainly
climate changes a big issue I think
there's a far more pragmatic and
realistic solution on the horizon which
is already showing signs of huge success
and that is a tech solution to this
problem
because we talked about you're saying
that after after having a child the next
biggest factor is selling your car
avoiding long haul flights and being
following very soon within 30 to 50
years we're all going to be driving
electric or being driven around in
shared electric cars I I think the same
will apply to flights and you talk about
vegetarianism within 30 to 50 years
there will be an identical replacement
to meat that would be grown in the labs
and I think the tech approach to this is
gonna fix most of the problem in can I
just let me just see the graphic again
because yes driverless cars
vegetarianism these are all great but
they are completely eclipsed by the
carbon imprint of having an extra child
and that's why I'm just think don't do
these other things but why do we talk so
much about these things and we never
even mention the fact that the extra
children that we have are having this
huge impact we're not having enough
children well there are the tensions
we're having this conversation in the
United Kingdom admittedly it can be seen
all around the world with Sky News but
the nine countries that are projected to
have the work most of the world's
population growth over the next two or
three decades are in order India Nigeria
the Congo Pakistan Ethiopia Tanzania the
USA Uganda and Indonesia you're neatly
notice there that the UK didn't feature
so whatever we do here why can't I have
any form or have a little bit of har har
and have a baby and dry vac over the
question you whine it right the average
British person produces about seven tons
of carbon in their lifetime
put that double that for you
[Applause]
the average person in Bangladesh
produces half a tonne in their lifetime
so each extra child someone in a
developed country has has a much greater
impact than sorry those figures are
correct but I still think I get your
issues with the extrapolation yes yes
only the population project projections
that Rachel read they are also based on
certain assumptions actually the rates
of reproduction in those countries are
falling and so very much but they are
falling and I think they will continue
to pour les prosperity Rises and it's
about prosperity that if we bring tech
solutions in that we can find solutions
professor Nawaz has just told us that
soon we're gonna have meat that isn't me
yeah we'll find a solution to the carbon
crisis anyway then so we can carry this
solution is we're all gonna have sex
with robots
I am not saying we should be like China
have a one-child policy and start
policing it I'm just saying there are a
lot of people who feel very conscious
about climate change so they can try
really well the first thing is that
ambien that go probably doing that I've
got kids how many two three and I'm one
of six as well and my father is a
population experts they can imagine
not much teasing he's the course of his
lifetime and I have to say he completely
agrees with effort for every reason
you've got to bring down population both
in the West and in the day you don't
care about climate change what I said
was if you're someone who cares about
climate change and your solution to that
is not to have more children
brilliant good for you I do care but I'm
not gonna say and as a result I won't
have children and that's not gonna
happen but would you consider limiting
the number of children have now that you
know there's a statistic I just realized
something
the statistic will have no influence on
my number of children light bulb moment
no light bulb the reason that they have
such a big carbon imprint these children
that we're not meant to have is because
they're doing all the behaviors that I'm
saying my text solutions will fix in the
first place basic no but so the point is
though
they get it so they're gonna grow up to
eat meat dry totally gonna have very low
no but if we get rid of this stuff we
won't have to worry about the population
element to this because the only reason
they'll have a carbon imprint is if
they're continuing to eat meat drive
petrol driven cars so this fix the
problem for what it is which is which is
the cars and the flights and the meat
but you see which is gonna influence my
decision I I don't want to tell anyone
else what choices to make that's but I
when I learned about this I have one
child I would love to have more children
will you have a second I would love to
have more children but when I learned
about this it did make me think I feel
like somebody who's committed to trying
to help reduce climate change and now
that I know that every child I have is
going to have such a big contribution to
carbon emissions it just I'm not saying
I won't have it will definitely make you
think because if we fix these problems
your child won't have well we're gonna
fix them we're all trapped if we're
gonna fix we wouldn't think about
conserving energy we have to conserve
our energy for the next debate because